it didn't take long Pokemon go has
become a global sensation only days
after was released fans are wild for the
augmented reality game which sends
Pokemon trainers out into their
neighborhoods and communities on a quest
to catch them all
and naturally the massive popularity of
the app means we've already learned
plenty of tips and tricks here's a list
of what all you trainers should watch
out for as you play and as well as a few
real-life issues that trainers have
encountered along the way
don't waste your stuff the first lesson
we learned when playing Pokemon go is
that time consumables run on real time
not in-game time if you use one of these
items and the game crashes for an hour
you'll log back in and find your buff
already expired don't use an incense
lure module or lucky egg unless you have
30 minutes available to make the most of
it don't trespass game developer Niantic
isn't new to the augmented reality game
in their previous release ingress users
visit and claim local points of interest
for their team Niantic reuse these same
points of interest when developing the
locations for Pokemon go so be smart
don't risk the wrath of property owners
or authorities by trying to reach these
same locations in Pokemon go don't miss
the Intel one major drawback of Pokemon
go is the lack of a mapping tool some
unofficial maps have sprung up but none
are as complete or as easy to use as the
official map made for ingress as we
mentioned before Niantic recycled its
ingress portal locations for Pokemon go
so do yourself a favor download the game
and sign up for an account even if you
don't plan on playing you can use the
ingress online Intel tool to easily find
your nearest portals which are also gems
or poker stops again I would like you
all to come in to my polka stop
restaurants here in Mililani mauka as
well as my wife hall location so thank
you very much hope to see you at my
polka sub restaurants and if you wind up
at this dude's fish restaurant in Hawaii
you've walked too far
better check that map again don't catch
and drive this should be obvious but
don't swipe away with your pokeball in
the car while you can technically catch
wild Pokemon at any speed is it really
worth the risk
you should only be driving to get to
your location then get out and get some
exercise that's the point of the entire
game after all
well that and for Nintendo to earn a
bunch of money after the Wii U flopped
ditch those extra piggies if you play
enough you'll probably have a lot of
extra piggies or other low-level
pokemons knocking around did you know
that you can exchange them for something
better if you transfer a Pokemon to
Professor willow he'll give you one
species specific candy in exchange
you'll also get three candies every time
you catch a new Pokemon and because you
use candies to powerup and evolve your
Pokemon you can catch and transfer
nineteen pidgeys and have enough candy
to evolve xx 1 all the way to Pidgeot of
course when we eat that much candy we
don't evolve into anything we just do
this don't evolve without a lucky egg
speaking of evolution you should always
have a lucky egg active before you
evolve a Pokemon lucky eggs are
different from regular eggs and don't
require an incubator
they give double xp for 30 minutes
ideally you'll want to have enough candy
on hand to evolve several Pokemon in a
row go to your items menu and select a
lucky egg then tap it on your screen to
activate it next start evolving of
course when we eat lucky eggs we don't
get any extra XP we just do this
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to share your tips for Pokemon
go